hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fears to fathom the first
in an episodic series of horror games
where you're home alone
funding for yourself
or something like that boom home alone i
just set up some traps and that'll take
care of any invaders
easy peasy paint buckets nails on the
stairs a shotgun to the face
problem solved i didn't want to put this
up on reddit just for it to be called a
piece of fiction
i don't even know where to start
so i guess i'll start at the beginning
excuse my lack of good storytelling
skills
i don't talk very good i guess i'll just
start that's pretty much exactly what i
said all right and then what
it was the middle of summer my parents
had left for that weekend due to a work
trip which meant i was all by myself for
the weekend they went on vacation
without you also i feel like i do have
to mention that my sleep schedule was
really messed up around this time i
would sleep and get up at just about any
time of day though i did plan on fixing
that
but my crippling addiction to
masturbation kept me awake at all hours
oh that's not good
hello
ah oh it's my alarm
i woke up around eight after a nap that
evening
your sleep schedule is messed up
also
very panic inducing alarm you got there
oh nice book
is that the what
no
ah this is probably my plan to
stop the intruders
anywho lovely evening
yo
hi mom
it's probably fine no need to order
anything already made you lasagna this
morning check the fridge
oh how's kem
totally forgot probably gonna do it
tonight little saying my parents are out
for the night want to come over we can
play mario kartly you know okay call
josh too can't promise may have plans
with nat
nat
whatever
would abandon his bro
don't ask me why but i went straight to
my parents room
i did not know this was my parents room
but here i am
any money any drugs
alcogol hello who are you
hi
how you doing
how you doing pal
what's going on pal
how you uh how you be
what were you doing in my driveway well
i'm a little perturbed
why would i need to do that
hello
peekaboo
peek my blue okay fine where's this
lasagna
hello
oh i see what's happening oh i'm gonna
need to know about that
oh i'm gonna need to do something about
that i need to warm up the food
i sure did
oh
beautiful lasagna
food was cold
throw it in the oven all right
put it in the oven
chokey peep
hello
it's fine
i don't like this i don't like this at
all this is this is the setup for
something bad
i can open that okay good who's in my
drive that was my driveway
that was my driveway if only my friend
josh were here and not hanging out with
nat
so lonely
food was already warm who eats at the
eyelid that is someone where would your
knees go
this is not a table
hello
anybody want some lasagna
well guess i'll just watch the telly
all right
well it's easy
can i eat it i like watching tv while i
ate
who doesn't
the whole concept of eating with nothing
in front of you so boring
okay am i eating
how do i eat it
i really want to eat it i guess i didn't
get any utensils i just gotta dig in
with my hand
well that was delicious okay here i am
again
okay
i'm just gonna well
god damn it mom you know i don't like
lasagna maybe i should turn the tv on
right
that's what it is
i see
[Music]
just dive head first i like to go
bobbing for lasagna
i was already feeling very sleepy after
eating food
anybody out there
[Music]
mason
oh wait i i texted mason not not josh
all right
cool mom we're gonna have to call it off
man something just came up but you gotta
come to jessica's tomorrow jessica
well
okay
i guess
i'm guessing i'm in high school or
something like that
ah did i leave that open
oh did i leave that open was that from
me
it's my property i can litter on it if i
want and that better actually close this
time hello we have two back doors
okay
hmm
suspicious
dog so full
who weighed down by all this lazani who
can eat a whole family size lasagna in
one i'm sorry miles gotta see you
tomorrow
huh
chill out dude all good i'll probably
just go back to bed after tim
yeah right
who does homework
what am i a nerd can i did that's a pull
curtain
no see the crouch this one i saw poker
well time to close my goddamn door
maybe sit down
i'm doing homework
12 38 a.m
man that took a while i got done with
the homework for the day in about a few
hours
i don't have a computer
this is pre-computer times no there was
a flat screen i'm assuming there's a
computer
no it says something about video games
because i'm not allowed to have a
computer in my room dude my crippling
porn addiction
i got a big room
don't stay up too late you kids i
shouldn't get to hear from mrs paula
this time yeah don't worry mason's over
with
not
big room small bed
well i guess i'll hit the hay
partying it up
1 16 a.m i got up to get some water sure
i did
sure i did sure definitely i did
definitely doing that
that's an awfully
loud clock
don't like this
i don't like this at all
hello
um
you know they weren't joking
i've been in a lot of houses in horror
games for some reason the idea
what is that
it's fine it's nothing
what is that
it's nothing it's fine water
water
once
the bringer of life
water
glug
refreshing
more please
one more
hmm
now that's good
uh mom will take care of it
what is
that someone
or something hello
huh
no signal
that's a little strange
hello
i can't go out oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what
the hell what happened
was just out there
oh god i gotta start over again
okay well that was unexpected hmm turns
out you shouldn't open the door
he was hiding in my blind spot all right
speedrun time
well this time i ain't gonna get dead
united
shut up
that dude isn't there there anymore i
guess i didn't go to the parents room
and that's where i would see it
him
it
what was that what was that what did i
just see was that a shadow
i swear to god i saw a shadow right
there i swear
i just saw that
i swear i did
is the back door cracked open was that
me
or was that someone
[Music]
no
that wasn't me
oh no
oh no there was someone there's someone
in my pocket there's someone in my
parents room
mom
dad
[Music]
who the hell
who
in the hell
was in here
who in the hell
no thank you
do we have a dog
[Music]
i don't like that i don't like that at
all i don't like that nun
oh mom yeah okay no no don't worry mom
don't worry mom
just going to get some
sleep
okay
now rule number one here
do not
go outside
just get some water
i'm not going in there
i ain't going in there and i'm no way
is he out there
is he there
i can't see him
is he there
can't tell
oh why
what happened oh no let's see music
just the music it's fine
glug
glug
and glove
okay
good
now i'm just gonna go right
back to bed
i'm going back to bed i'm going back to
bed i'm going back to bed
i'm going back to bed
i'm screaming loudly
to nobody
going back
did i close my door
[Music]
definitely definitely sure i i
absolutely did definitely 100 100 100
[Music]
miles who's that at the door
i don't know who is at the door
i don't know
thank you nosy neighbor please call the
police
call the police
[Music]
said he's been creeping through the
windows we're calling the cops don't
answer the door no matter what he does
should i have locked the door was i
supposed to go down and lock the door
was i supposed to go lock the door ah
i don't wanna
i'm brave i'm brave i'm brave i'm going
to do it
i'm going to do it
i bet i was doing what i said lock every
door and hide in your room
why are you there and why do you have an
ominous red light on your face am i
supposed to do something i there was no
option to lock the door
there's no option to lock the door
and i'm not gonna trust clicking on it
that's how i died last time so i'm gonna
go upstairs i'm gonna go in my room and
i'm gonna go to bed
just gonna go to bed
where's my bed knife
where's my bed knife
click to hide
where where hide what do you mean hide
you said click to hide click to hide i'm
hiding
i'm hiding
you'll never find me down here
oh
oh that's not good
no thank you
i'm good
[Music]
it's paula at the door
mom's so sorry honey everything's gonna
be
oh who is he do you hear her it's paul
at the door
mom's so sorry honey i don't trust it
nope mine trust in it
but what if it is
uh
ah you can't type back
is that a red ominous glow outside my
door
is that a red ominous glow right outside
this door right here
oh my god
[Music]
i mean the neighbor's house's lights are
all on now i guess
hey
nope
you know what nope i'm gonna go with my
gamer instinct on this one i'm gonna say
no
oh my
goodness is that for real that's for
real okay that's for real
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hey yeah
you were just waiting for me to go
downstairs so you could snatch me out of
that door you [ __ ] that's what the
breaking of the window was about
please
cops please
hello
can i go outside now
are you there
police officer at my door yes okay hello
hello hi
i'm dead
god damn that was terrifying
i was legitimately i was legitimately
freaked out there i haven't been in a
situation in a horror game where i was
that afraid to do anything in a long
time and i think this game was fantastic
and that it gave you a profound sense of
helplessness right i didn't know what
would kill me i knew there was something
out there that the moment it got me i'm
dead and i felt that really really good
i haven't felt true terror like that in
a while and it was such a simple concept
but oh so well executed there's another
episode of this that i'm gonna play
next
so
look forward to that thank you everybody
so much for watching uh let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
are there other secrets in this game
because i was so paranoid to explore
nothing because i didn't want to die let
me know if you find anything down in the
description below there's a link to play
the game so thank you and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]